BARBARA IMPERIALI:
OK, we'll get started.
I've got everything
turned on here.
So, a couple of things.
I've been mentioning that
it's really kind of cool,
I think, at this
stage, where you've
gathered enough steam
in some of the topics
that many things that
come out in the news
might start looking of
interest or relevant to you.
And I found this.
It had a news brief
in The Scientist,
and then I went to the
original paper, which
is in Nature Biotechnology.
And if you recall, towards the
end of the work on proteins,
we were talking about
phenylketonuria,
which is a genetically
linked disorder,
where people cannot metabolize
phenylalanine to keep
the levels of fell
phenylalanine in check.
So what happens is
the phenylalanine
gets converted to
a toxic material,
and it causes a lot of
fundamental physiologic
disorders that are a lot
of neurologic disorders.
So what a small company
in the area called--
what's the name of the company?
I can see it here.
Anyway.
Synlogic is a synthetic
biology company,
which basically engineers
bacterial strains
as probiotics that can
be used to mitigate
some genetic disorders.
And so they've created
a bacterial strain that
can metabolize
phenylalanine, so did
a good job of sort of not
letting your phenylalanine
levels get too high.
So in the GI system,
this bacterium basically
works on phenylalanine
to metabolize it
so that, then, people
don't have to lead
such a strict dietary regime
and have way less risk.
So I think it's a
really cool thing.
This probiotic is in
one, two clinical trials.
It's being fast tracked.
And the company, in general,
is a synthetic biology company
working on solutions to
certain types of diseases
that could either save you from
having a lot of restrictions
on your lifestyle or,
alternatively, save you
from taking
medications and stuff.
So that's something
that caught my eye.
I want to remind you
that I have now put
the link to The Scientist in
the sidebar of the website
so it's much easier for
you to grab it and take
a look at what's in the news.
There's stuff in the news
every two or three days.
And there are
things that I think
you'll find interesting that
really relate to technology,
engineering, and
fundamental science
that are related to biology.
The other thing I want
to do is remind you
that towards the
end of the class--
but no time like the
present, because it
is sort of the equivalent
of one of the problem sets
but, in fact, worth a little
bit more than the problem set.
I want to encourage you to keep
an eye on The Scientist link
and maybe pick out a topic
that two or three of you
would like to write a news brief
on with a paragraph of writing
on introduction and
what the technology is,
how technology has addressed
a particular scientific or
biological problem.
And then there should also be
a graphic that describes it.
Not stuff snipped out of
whatever you're reading.
Something that you create
as a team to sort of
describe a concept to people.
There's alternatives
with that assignment.
You can also pick an interesting
protein from the PDB,
make a 3D print of it,
learn how to print it,
and go to the 3D printers
in the maker labs,
and print the protein,
and then write
a brief summary of what it is.
And one other idea I had
for the engineers' view
is I would love a
better, less clunky
topoisomerase demonstration.
In particular, I'd
really like one
where you can snip
the pieces apart, let
the untangling happen, and
put them back together.
So some of you could work
with a couple of colleagues
and make something,
which I know a lot of you
are really keen on, which
is why you're engineers.
OK, any questions
about any of this?
I'm trying to make sure that
this doesn't creep up on you.
It's just something you do.
It's great to get awareness of
technology in the life sciences
because of how much
contribution it makes.
So if you keep an
eye on things, you
won't be forced to suddenly
find something good
at the last minute.
You'll just have found
something and go,
that's the perfect
thing to describe.
All right?
Questions?
And the other thing
is if you're unsure,
you can always let us
know what you have chosen
or what you think you're going
to choose in the chat with us,
and we'll say, yeah,
looks like a good idea.
OK, so let's move forward now.
All right, so what I
want to do, first of all,
is just remind you-- it kind
of flew by a little bit--
that DNA replication
is bidirectional.
So what that means
is wherever you
have an origin of
replication, you can
replicate in two directions.
And I was sort of falling
asleep thinking about this.
I sure wonder what
happens at the other side
of the circular plasmid when
the machineries kind of collide
and you spit out
a brand-new copy
of a circular chunk of DNA.
But don't think
about that too much.
It'll probably keep
you awake too much.
So this is circular DNA.
So what organisms
have circular DNA?
AUDIENCE: Prokaryotes.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Prokaryotes.
Remember, the eukaryotic
DNA is linear.
And actually,
we're going to talk
about a conundrum with
the eukaryotic DNA because
of the ends of the DNA,
the ends of the chromosomes
and their copying, when
we talk about telomerase.
But this is typical of a
bacterial circular DNA.
It's usually super coiled
and becomes uncoiled in order
to be replicated.
So, obviously, going
bidirectionally
gives you twice the speed,
because your roaring
around the same time.
The helicase opens up the DNA.
DNA polymerase does its job.
The pink strand here would
be the leading strand.
And there's obviously going to
be one on both strands of DNA,
which will replicate very well.
But don't forget,
you're going to have
to deal with the lagging
strands in both cases.
So in both cases,
what you would do
is stick down a
primer in order to be
able to build those
lagging strands.
Otherwise, DNA polymerase
can't get a grip
on the double-stranded
DNA in order
to carry out the synthesis.
So in those cases,
there would be a primer
to set up the lagging strand,
and then DNA synthesis
can occur.
So let's put that in.
Once there's a primer here,
DNA synthesis can occur.
And then what happens
with respect to the pieces
that we're dealing with?
What happens with the primer?
What do we have to do to get to
a nice complete, intact strand
of DNA?
Which enzymes are involved?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Ligase.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Here, there
would be ligase activity.
We need that.
What about at the other end?
What do we do with the
primer, and then how
can we move forward?
Someone else?
What happens with the primer?
It's oftentimes an RNA primer.
You'll see in a moment that
RNA doesn't need a primase,
so it's very easy
for RNA polymerase
to stitch in little pieces.
What do we have to do, though,
to get an intact strand of DNA?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Have to
remove the [? RNA. ?]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yup.
So you're going
to remove the RNA.
Then the polymerase, later
on, when we keep going,
can sort of build this piece.
And then we'll have to
ligate that, as well.
So you want to remember all the
functions of those enzymes that
are involved in replication.
It's a little
worrisome that people--
I know you don't
want to talk or you
think that's an obvious answer,
but it's really important
that you have them at
your fingertips, some
of these enzymes that are
involved in this process.
Because they should start
to become second nature.
When you have to make a full
DNA copy of an entire genome,
there's a lot of moving parts.
But if you start walking
through the logic of them,
they make sense.
If I'm going to unpeel
DNA, I need a helicase.
If I'm going to keep
it single stranded,
I need single strand
binding proteins.
If I'm going to move forward,
sure, I need the polymerase,
but what does the
polymerase need?
It needs a primer in order
to have double strand,
because DNA
polymerase only wants
to lock onto a double strand
to go start doing its job.
These complications
with the lagging
strands that are
really annoying,
but it's pretty remarkable
nature has addressed this
and is able, remember,
to replicate DNA
and bacteria at a speed of
100 base pairs per second.
So that's what's going
on, this entire process.
Excuse me.
1,000 base pairs a second.
I just want you to
remember this process is
slower in eukaryotes.
It's about 30 to 50
base pairs per second.
Obviously, when you're speeding,
you make more mistakes,
so there are more mistakes in
bacterial genome replication.
Why does it not matter
so much if there's
a mistake in a bacterial genome?
What do you know about
bacteria and their lifestyles?
Do they stick
around a long time?
No.
So they divide quickly.
They live and die quickly.
So you're not having to keep an
intact genome without mistakes
in it for a long time,
because you're just
turning over bacteria.
If there's a mistake,
it probably dies out.
Or heaven forbid, there's
resistance to drugs developed.
And we'll talk
about those later,
because those occur
due to mistakes
and in bacterial replication.
But in a eukaryotic
genome, we have
to preserve the
integrity of the genome.
So I'm going to talk
about two things that
are related to the
accuracy of replication
now, because that's a
really important component.
All right, so the first
thing is to think about,
what's the basal rate of making
mistakes of DNA polymerase?
So for that purpose,
I'm just going
to put down a piece of DNA
with its partner that's
being synthesized, five
prime to three prime.
And I'll put in some
bases, so A. So that
would have had a
T put in opposite.
G, that would have had a C.
So these have two
hydrogen bonds.
These have three hydrogen bonds.
And let's say we
now have a C here.
So we want to put in a G
at the position opposite.
DNA polymerase wants to
add the next base pair.
It should be a G,
because it's going
in opposite a C. It's being
grown in the right direction,
five prime to three prime.
So the basal error rate
is about 1,000 to 1.
So 999 times out of 1,000,
the right base gets put in.
1 time out of 1,000, you
might put in the wrong rate.
So the error rate is
about 1 in 10 to the 3.
That's really all that's--
all that's at play
here is energetics,
just how favorable putting
in the right base is.
But there's a slight chance that
the wrong base will just go in.
Because the energetics are
sufficiently different,
but you're going
to make mistakes,
just because of the
thermodynamic balance.
If you're putting
in 999, you're going
to get it wrong some of the
time, just statistically,
because the difference
in energy between putting
in the right base or
putting in a wrong base.
So that error rate is too high.
If we replicated our genome,
32 billion base pairs,
and we had a 1 in 10
to the 3 error rate,
we'd have a lot of mistakes
in the genome, right?
And we cannot tolerate that,
because all those mistakes
in our genome will then
propagate to mistakes
in our proteome, if we're in the
right segments of the genome.
So this is pretty unacceptable
with respect to an error rate.
So one way that
nature deals with this
is that DNA polymerase actually
does some proofreading,
all right?
So it has a
proofreading function.
So what do you do?
When you're proofreading,
you take a quick look
at what you've just written and
say, oh, yeah, that looks good.
That looks good.
So what DNA polymerase
is-- it more or less
reaches back to the base it
puts in and checks that it's OK.
It can only proofread
one base back.
It can't proofread
from work that's
been done a long time ago.
It can just proofread
very recent work.
And if it looks like
it's the wrong base,
DNA polymerase has
an opposite function.
It has what's known as a three
prime exonuclease activity.
So I'll write that
down, and then we'll
talk about what that means.
Three prime exonuclease.
So let's say we put in,
instead of G, we put in a T.
That's bad news.
So what it can do is it
can reach back and cut off,
from the three prime end, a
single nucleotide, the one that
just got put in, all right?
And then allow the
process to reoccur
to get the right base pair in.
So a lot of enzymes will
catalyze both forwards
and backwards reactions.
DNA polymerase, the
energetics of such
are that it is able
to catalyze both
the addition of a
nucleotide and the removal
of a single nucleotide, only
if it's at the three prime end.
Only if it's at an open end,
where it's just been put in.
So, remember, the DNA
polymerase is still here,
because its plan is to
move forward and keep
on putting in nucleotides.
But it actually checks back.
You could picture
DNA pol just sort
of quickly looking
over its shoulder
at the work it's just done and
realizing that's the wrong one.
So what this does is brings the
error rates down considerably.
Goes in 1 in 10 to the 5.
So that's way better.
1 in 100,000 is much better,
and that's pretty acceptable.
So it means you're really
making very minimal mistakes
in the replication.
So this part, the proofreading,
brings the error rate
from 1 in 10 to the 3
to 1 in 10 to the 5.
But it can only work during
DNA polymerase activity,
and it can only work on the
most recent nucleotide that
has been put in.
So this is basically a
summary of-- yes, question?
AUDIENCE: So are [INAUDIBLE]
in prokaryotes and eukaryotes?
BARBARA IMPERIALI: They
are, and they are similar--
actually, there's slightly
less error rates in eukaryotes,
because the speed is slower.
So the opportunity to
fix things is going
to be a little bit better.
So, in the end,
your goal, really,
is to bring your error rate
between 10 to the 5 and 10
to the 6.
But for bacteria, because
the speed is so much larger,
this is sort of the limit of it.
But in eukaryote, it can
be a little bit better,
because the speed is slower.
So you could imagine, if
you're quickly proofreading,
you're doing a less good
job than if you're slowly
proofreading.
But the enzymes that
I'll talk to you
about in a second in eukarya
are to fix entire work that's
already been done.
We'll see that in a moment.
And that's what
really cleans up.
These enzymes are called
the guardians of the genome,
and they are much more
sophisticated in eukarya.
So that's a very good point.
All right, so here's
the general scheme.
There is an extension.
There's a mistake.
So there's proofreading.
The mistake gets taken out.
And then you keep on
extending again, all right?
So this now becomes pretty good.
But what we need to
talk about now is,
what are the enzymes
that go to work--
and I'm leaving
what's on that board
there, because I'm going
to come back to it--
to actually correct
mistakes in DNA.
So let's talk about the
guardians of the genome.
Because remember that your
DNA is your permanent record
of what needs to be made.
All right, so the
types of mistakes
that can be fixed
with proofreading
are only recent mistakes.
The types of enzymes
I'm going to talk to you
about mistakes that
are found globally
within double-stranded DNA.
And these are mistakes wherever.
They may be mistakes that didn't
get corrected by proofreading.
But more importantly,
they're mistakes
that occur due to some
kind of damage on the DNA.
So what kind of things might
impact the integrity of our DNA
on a day-to-day basis?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sunlight.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Sunlight.
So terrible stuff.
UV light will actually
cause some cross-links,
and I'll show you one of those,
that are very serious in DNA.
What else might hurt the genome?
So sunlight.
People say, don't go
out in the sunlight.
They're right about that.
What else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Radiation.
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
Radiation is another form.
So that's like radioactivity.
Radiation is important, right?
So if our ozone layer gets
thin, there's more risk there,
as well.
What about barbecue?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Harmful chemicals.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yeah.
Awful chemicals, terrible
chemicals, right.
So chemicals.
So these are things like
polyaromatic structures
that actually slip into your
genome and cause mistakes
in the reading.
Or they actually
physically modify
the bases to make it a base
that doesn't look like a base
anymore.
So these are commonly
very reactive chemicals.
So these are all very
serious things to the genome.
And so the enzymes that
mitigate the damage to the DNA
basically screen along
the double-stranded DNA
to look for defects.
Because if you have perfectly
paired DNA, then you're not--
you're going to have a
very regular structure.
Whereas, if something
has happened to the DNA,
there's something
wrong with the base--
it's not base pairing well
or something has actually
happened between
bases where they're
causing a bulge in the genome--
then these enzymes
will come into play.
About a few years ago--
actually, it was on a class
day, so I always enjoy these.
The Nobel Prize
was awarded in 2015
for the researchers who
deciphered the mechanisms
for correcting the genome
through DNA repair mechanisms.
So there are two
basic mechanisms
that I'll talk to you about.
One is base excision repair.
And the other one is
a lot more serious.
It's actually the entire
nucleotide excision repair.
So one fixes just the
base that's gone wrong,
but the other one takes much
more of the structure out
to fix it.
So it's nucleotide
excision repair.
So BER and NER, and
we're going to talk
about both of those
mechanisms, because they're
very fascinating.
And they kind of lean on some
of what you've learned already.
So base excision
repair occurs when
there's a defect in the base.
Maybe it's the wrong base.
Maybe it's just been
modified a little bit.
So what happens in base excision
repair is that the base gets--
all right, I'm going to
just use the pointer,
because my little
spotlight-- it'll pop back.
It's a bit magical.
So base excision repair, only
the base, a single localized
base, is damaged.
There is some
chemistry, for example,
that will convert cytosine to
uracil called a deamination
mechanism.
And in fact, if you replace
the cytosine with a uracil,
then you get in
trouble with respect
to its base pairing with its
appropriate purine partner.
So in base excision
repair, what will happen
is that base will be detected.
It will be flipped out from the
context of double-stranded DNA.
If it's tucked in the
double-stranded DNA,
you can't quite
cut the bond that's
attached from the ribose
sugar to the base.
So the base gets flipped
out of the DNA structure.
And there's an enzyme
known as a glycosylase that
cuts the bond between
the ribose and the base
and gets rid of it.
And then what happens is
the rest of the nucleotide,
just that one
nucleotide, gets removed.
And then DNA polymerase
fills the gap,
and the strand is
sealed by a ligase.
So a glycosylase
cuts the base out.
There's a couple of
enzymes that actually
cut the ribose, the
phosphodiester linkages out.
And then the two
enzymes, remember,
that are important
when we're making
DNA, the polymerase
and the ligase,
work together to put a
base into this position.
And then they put
the base back in,
and then the ligase
joins the gap.
So DNA polymerase will
make one of the bonds.
The ligase will make the
other bond, all right?
So that's base excision
repair, and it's
monitored by finding that
there is a lack of integrity
in the double-stranded DNA.
It's only a base
that's affected,
so that base gets removed.
The rest of the nucleotide is
removed, but only one of them.
And then they're replaced
through the concerted action
of polymerase and ligase.
Now, there is another mechanism
that's much more serious,
and this is very typical
of the types of damage
that get formed from
sunlight and UV radiation,
is when two thymidines are
adjacent to each other, they
will undergo, quite commonly,
a chemical reaction where
they form a dimeric structure.
So there's much more
wrong with the DNA
strand in that situation.
So those get noticed.
This thing's driving me nuts.
Those get noticed as a
real defect in the DNA.
Base excision repair won't work.
Why wouldn't it work?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because the
two are bound together.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yeah,
they're bound together.
You can't peel them back out.
You can't break
in that structure.
So you've got to move to a
much more sort of major fixing
of the DNA strand.
So there is a genetically
linked disorder
where the enzymes involved
in nucleotide excision repair
do not work.
And when a child has a copy
of both defective genes
from the parents, both one
from the mother and the father,
it's impossible for them to
fix these defects in the DNA.
And they get a lot of
physiologic problems
like sort of scarring and
sunburns, barely anything
at all.
So this is a group of children
that are so afflicted with this
genetic disorders that they
cannot go out in the daytime
at all.
So you'll sometimes see they're
called Children of the Night,
because basically, they have
to flip their schedules.
They just can't
go near sunlight.
And if they go
out, they basically
have to be covered
from head to toe.
And that's including
their eyes, because you
can get sunburn of the eyes.
You can sort of see, in
some of these pictures,
that it looks really
serious defects.
And this is just the
external manifestation.
The internal manifestation would
be cases of skin cancer very,
very readily.
So if you don't have
at least one good copy
of the enzyme that does
nucleotide excision repair,
then you're in trouble.
And the defects are called--
it's called xeroderma
pigmentosum.
And there's actually
a lot of family groups
that get together, because
the best way is just
to form a sort of social network
so the children understand
what each other-- the
limitations that they all have.
And they can play
together and be
on these sort of
flipped schedules
in order to avoid any sunlight.
So, in this case, it's
essential to basically clip out
a large chunk of the DNA.
So what happens in this case
is that the DNA is recognized,
and then a large portion of
it-- about a dozen nucleotides--
are cleaved out.
And then, once again, DNA
polymerase fills the gap,
and DNA ligase
seals the last gap.
So DNA polymerase
will be able to fill
going from the five
prime to three prime.
There'll still be one gap,
and then the ligase fixes it.
So I think these
kinds of things that
are done to mitigate
damage on the genome
are very important
to understand,
because this is
happening all the time.
Any minor things
that get fixed, that
need fixing due to sunlight,
radiation, chemicals
will be fixed
through these methods
to keep that rate, that error
rate, in your genome down to,
like, one in a billion
or something like that.
All right, I'm just
going to flash this up.
I'm going to, very quickly.
I'm going to give you
guys a copy of this.
But these are the
components that you
want to be able to understand
the function of when
thinking about DNA replication.
So you don't have
that on your slides,
but we're going to give you
a copy so that you can really
make sure that you understand
all the moving parts
and how they come
together for replication.
Now I want to talk about
one last conundrum with DNA,
and that is the
issue of telomerase.
And this is particularly
critical in eukaryotes
that have linear chromosomes.
Now, if you think about
DNA being replicated,
when you look at the
two strands of DNA,
as you approach the very
end of the chromosome,
you'll do just fine making the
copy that's built five primes--
sorry about this.
You'll do just fine
making the copy that
is built in this
direction, because it's
the leading strand.
And it's built five prime.
Am I going wrong here?
It's built five
prime to three prime.
Can someone help me out here?
I'm losing my mind.
So this piece is built
five prime to three prime,
so therefore, this was
five prime and three prime.
But then on the
other strand, you
have a problem, because you
need to put in a primer here
in order to build
the other strand.
Does that make sense?
So we've got to have put
in that short primer,
because DNA polymerase is
will not work otherwise.
And then we need to
build this strand of DNA.
All right, so what's the
problem here with respect
to these ends?
What's going to happen next?
If it's an RNA primer,
what happens next?
We nibble it up, right,
with the full intention
of replacing that bit of DNA.
But then what can
DNA polymerase do?
It can't do anything, right?
DNA polymerase needs
double-stranded DNA
to hold on to so it
could fill this gap.
So what happens is every
time you replicate DNA,
you end up with a gap,
with a small amount
you don't quite copy.
Is everyone following me?
And that's a problem, right?
Because doesn't
it mean every time
my cells divide, my genes
get a little bit shorter
and a little bit shorter
and a little bit shorter?
So there are things
in place that help.
One important feature
is that, usually, you
don't have important
genetic material
at the ends of your genes--
at the ends of
chromosomes, rather.
There's sort of extra DNA that
doesn't need to be copied.
But the basic theory, the
whole theory about telomerase,
is that for certain
types of cells--
these ascend stem
cells and germ cells--
there is an enzyme
that can fill this gap.
It's called telomerase.
So in those cells-- what's
special about these types
of cells?
We need to keep them good.
They're what defines
your starting DNA.
The stem cells and
the germ cells,
like in the sperm and egg, have
to have a good copy of DNA.
They can't be getting
shorter and shorter
every time a new
generation is born.
But once your cells
are the somatic cells,
the DNA gets
shorter and shorter,
because those cells
don't have telomerase.
And this is associated
with theories of aging.
So the cells you get,
the ones that are finally
the ones in your
body, every time
they divide, the ends
of the chromosomes
will get a little shorter.
But there's no mechanism
to replace those.
And so it's associated
with the belief
that, at a certain stage, you've
divided the cells enough times.
And then you can't--
you're actually starting to
nibble into important coding
DNA.
Does everybody
understand what would
be the significance of that?
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So once
the [INAUDIBLE]
are gone, is this
[INAUDIBLE] able to divide?
BARBARA IMPERIALI: No.
So the telomerase keeps
the DNA in those types
of cells in good condition.
In the cells that divide
daily, and your body wants--
the somatic cells.
You will keep on
shortening, but they'll just
be more mistakes, basically.
And those are the
sorts of things
that would be associated
with an organism that's
growing to a certain
age, because it's just
a certain number of cells.
So the cells may
not divide, or there
may be mistakes in certain
parts of the coding genome.
Any other questions?
OK, so telomerase was also
another important discovery
that was awarded a Nobel Prize.
And this gives you details.
So the telomerase protects
the genetic information
on every cell
division, though you
will lose a little bit
of genetic information.
So it limits the
number of divisions
a cell can make in a lifetime.
All right, so we're
going to move on now.
And I've spent quite
a bit of time on this,
but I want to
guarantee you that now,
as we move forward
to transcription,
there's a few simplifications
that we can make
in the story of transcription.
So moving on.
All right.
So what have we done so far?
We've seen replication.
Now we're moving to the
process of transcription.
So when you
transcribe something,
you're basically making
a copy of something,
but in a slightly
different format.
So, for example, if you're
transcribing from handwritten
to a typed version,
you go from something
that's in the script to
something that's typed.
It has the same content, but
it's in a different format.
So this is what the
process is called
when you convert DNA into RNA.
And very specifically,
this is part
of the process to make what's
known as the messenger RNA.
The first phase of transcription
in eukaryotic cells
gets us to a pre-messenger RNA.
So there's a little
bit more needs
to be done to it before
it can leave the nucleus
to encode protein translation.
But in bacteria,
you're basically
just going straight from the
DNA to the messenger RNA.
At the beginning
of the next class,
we will also talk about going
from the pre-messenger RNA
to the messenger RNA.
And let's take a
look at the cell
up here, where what
we're focusing in on here
is the process whereby
we're copying that DNA.
I have no idea why
this is really being
monstrously behaved like that.
I'm done, done
with these gizmos.
The process whereby the
double-stranded DNA opens up
a little bit and we make
that pre-messenger RNA
copy, all right?
So I want you to think
back to the processes
that we learned about
for translation.
And now we're going
to move forward
to take a look at transcription.
And frankly, it's a lot simpler.
So let's just look at the
players in transcription.
And you've got a copy
of this in your notes,
so I don't need to necessarily
put it all on the board.
So in DNA, remember, we had a A,
G, C, T. We have a deoxyribose,
and it's mostly used as
hereditary genetic information.
But in RNA, we're
making a new copy
of the DNA, where we use
slightly different building
blocks--
A, G, C, U. U
instead of T. Plus,
there are some
modified bases that
occur in some of the types of
RNA, and the sugar is a ribose.
So the first main thing
about the RNA copy
relative to the DNA copy is that
ribose/deoxyribose difference.
What's quite
remarkable is that when
you have two deoxyribose in
your DNA, it's nice and stable.
We need it to be
nice and stable.
It's our genome.
We can't let our
genome be falling apart
as we're sort of
walking down the street.
In contrast, when RNA is used,
it's much more transient.
We make a messenger
RNA copy of part of DNA
to move forward
to make proteins,
but we don't need that
to stick around forever.
And when you have the ribose
with the two hydroxyls, a two
and three, it's a much
more fragile material.
It is a transient message, and
it gets degraded quite quickly.
So that difference
in the sugar really
dictates the stability there.
RNA is found in a lot of
polymers, biopolymers.
We'll talk we'll focus mostly
on the messenger RNA today.
It's less than 1% of the DNA.
And then on Friday, we'll be
talking about the transfer
RNA and the ribosomal RNA.
So we're really
going to focus in
right now on the messenger RNA.
And the one thing about RNA
structures I'll elaborate later
is they have very
different structures
to canonical DNA, which
adopts the double-stranded,
anti-parallel structure.
RNA structures are much more
like folded protein structures,
where there may be
sections of base pairing,
but there'll also
be lots of loops
and different characteristics.
So even the ribose
structure makes a difference
in the stability of the
double stranded structure
and encourages a lot more of
these unusual structures, which
is really why people
have a lot of faith
in the theories
about the RNA world.
OK, so let's look at DNA
polymerase, RNA polymerase.
So here's all the
good news that we'll
be able to describe to you.
So when you copy DNA,
you copy all of it.
When you copy RNA,
you only copy--
when you make the
copy of messenger RNA,
you only copy about
1.5% of the genome.
So you do not copy
the entire thing.
So the process is much more
restricted to sections of DNA
that need to be copied.
And we'll talk about the
features of the DNA that
tell you about that later.
Here's the important details.
So in eukaryotes, transcription
happens in the nucleus.
And the key enzyme involved
is RNA polymerase, RNA pol.
And it has very different
features to DNA polymerase,
but there are two big
things that are different.
It includes its own helicase.
So you remember,
with replication, we
needed a DNA polymerase
and a helicase.
RNA polymerase is much
smarter than that.
It actually includes both
functions within its structure.
So it's an RNA polymerase
that grows the new nucleotide
five prime to three prime.
But it also has a
built-in helicase,
so that's an advantage.
It still grows the messenger
RNA five prime to three prime,
but it uses the different
nucleotide triphosphate
building blocks.
Or one of them is different.
So UTP, ATP.
So remember, the U
replaces the T in RNA,
so that's one key difference.
It includes a helicase activity.
And the other really
neat thing, because it's
such a complication
in replication,
is it doesn't require a primer.
That is why even when we
were replicating the DNA,
we were using RNA
polymerase to make
those little pieces
of primers, because it
didn't need a priming sequence.
So there's really
fundamental differences
about the RNA polymerase.
And then the other thing
is that only one of the two
strands of DNA is transcribed.
And in a moment, or maybe
the beginning of next class,
we'll judge how
we can understand
which sequence is transcribed.
And then, obviously,
the messenger RNA
is a complementary sequence
to the sequence of DNA
that is being copied.
Finally, only part of
the DNA is transcribed,
under unlike the
process of replication.
All right, so you
can see already
that there are a lot
of simplifications
in transcription that we
did not have the advantage
of in replication.
So the helicase activity
and the primary issue
are two key features that
make life a lot simpler.
I just wanted to show you
this small detail about RNA
polymerase.
There are a lot of
natural products out there
that are known to be
inhibitors of vital processes,
and one that caught my eye
is the small molecules that
are found in mushrooms, the
really toxic mushrooms, when
you see some of these.
In fact, never eat a
mushroom that you don't know
and you know where it
came from, because there's
problems with them.
Because a lot of these
mushrooms include
potent natural products.
And in fact, there's
a compound known
as amanitin,
alpha-amanitin, and it's
found in certain mushrooms
known as either the Death Cap
or Destroying Angel mushrooms.
So you could tell
from their names
that they are a real problem.
And what the amanitin does is
it actually interferes directly
with RNA polymerase by acting as
an allosteric inhibitor of RNA
polymerase and locking
it into a closed state
so it can't keep
on transcribing.
So I thought this was very
interesting, incredibly.
Tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny doses
will arrest transcription
and cause dire consequences.
So I think what's very
interesting is that it's
an allosteric inhibitor.
It's very potent.
What it does is it
seals the polymerase
in a locked, closed state
that it can't move forward
for transcription.
Now, finally, a
couple of points.
When we decide that
a portion of gene
is going to be
transcribed, there
are a lot of mechanisms
in place to identify
the portion of that gene.
And one of the key
things that is known
is that there are what are
called promoter sites, which
are actually upstream
of the portion of gene
that's to be transcribed, where
you recruit a bunch of proteins
that actually park down on the
double-stranded DNA and then,
at the end of the day,
recruit the RNA polymerase.
So all that extra
genome, some of it
is not transcribed
into messenger RNA
for making proteins,
but it's part
of an area of the gene
that gets recognized
by all of the proteins
that collaborate
to bring in the RNA
polymerase in order
for your RNA to be transcribed.
So what I'm showing you here is
a double-stranded DNA with one
of the very common
promoters that's
just upstream of the part of
the DNA that gets transcribed.
And it's called the TATA box,
because it's T-A-T-A sequence.
It's got a complement
that looks like it.
And it's shown in pink here.
And then the proteins that
bind to the DNA at the TATA box
actually drape over that
segment of double-stranded DNA
and then serve as
recruitment entities
to bring in all the machinery
that's needed for transcription
of the gene beyond it.
So some of the identity of all
that extra double-stranded DNA
is actually guide
places to guide
where the machinery
for transcription
has to park in order for
messenger RNA to be formed.
So immediately, you
can see we're only
going to transcribe part of this
genetic material beyond here.
But we need a whole
bunch of genetic material
that's actually
just serving as sort
of the runway for the plane
landing in the right position,
all right?
So I'm going to put up a puzzle
that you can think about.
And then we'll start with
these at the beginning
of the next class, because
I don't want to rush them.
When you decide to
transcribe a gene--
let's say you've got
a promoter site here--
the thing that I want
you to think about
is, which strand
would you transcribe?
And what's the
logic behind this?
And then we'll just
do a recap on this
at the beginning
of the next class,
because I just want
you to think about it.
Because a lot of the information
you need is directly here.
Hi there.
We're just wrapping up.
OK?
So that's it for today.